right
thank you I
we got a big show Alicia big Cheryl and
I think I
great crowds we get down we got great
crowds the best
well I think that is what the good news
is that the blush may be off the Trump
Rose finally he's he's having a bit of a
bad week did you see what happened
yesterday a Trump was taking questions
at his Klan rally in New Hampshire and
he learned a very important lesson never
give the microphone to a man who thinks
Donald Trump should be President because
this guy got up there and he said to
Donald Trump a Obama's a Muslim birth
certificate man he's not even American
we know that and the Muslims have
training camps here ready to kill us
what are you gonna do about it
you know there's been a pet conspiracy
theory among the tea baggers for a long
time that Obama is setting up
re-education camps I'd like to say
tonight
I think he should really
re-education camp because you know I try
to resist comparisons to Hitler because
there's only one Hitler he broke them
all but you know what if you're stirring
up xenophobic hate among an angry
humiliated population and talking about
rounding up minorities it's a little
Hitler adjacent I guess
and also at this rally someone asked
Donald Trump if he was going to meet the
Pope when he comes here next week and
the Trump goes up well the Pope believes
in global warming I roll and that's what
you know the Pope is crazy when he
believes in things you can't see huh Wow
no I mean nobody at that rally believed
in global warming and less than half of
American conservatives less than half of
American Tara's have a favorable opinion
of the Pope 29 percent think he's a
Muslim it was just coming here to have
an anchor baby so I these are not well
informed people I'm just saying there's
a republic in Arizona Arizona Republican
congressman named Paul Gosar I believe
who said he's not going to attend the
Pope's speech before Congress because
the Pope he said has adopted all the
Socialists talking points yeah you mean
like the New Testament he has that's
true uh and finally in the finally in
the third hour of the debate yes the
debate was three hours I saw at the end
I think I saw Chris Christie starting to
eat his hand but in the third hour CNN
finally asked a question about climate
change of course they all blew it off
like oh I even talked about that they
didn't talk about climate change at all
didn't talk about the economy in coming
to call the whole thing was about how
it's important that we have a strong
[ __ ] president who everybody hates
whose code name is hammer of the gods
who wants to put his wife on the ten
dollar bill
and you know and discussing the debate
was held in the Reagan Library right in
front of Air Force one that Reagan used
to fly and of course the Reagan Library
is their church it is and like a
Christian Church they worship the
founder while ignoring everything he
ever taught Reagan raised taxes Reagan
gave amnesty to Mexican doesn't matter
but the question that question about
what woman would you put on the ten
dollar bill so important we had to find
that out and of course all these
[ __ ] up there that my mother my wife
Trump said my daughter the obvious
answer was Nancy Reagan these idiots
can't even pander on their feet she's
sitting right there it's like if they
said name a big thing that flies and
they couldn't come up with plane so the
two leading contenders now are Donald
Trump and dr. ben Carson what an odd
couple because Trump manic energy and
dr. ben Carson Wow I mean Trump accuses
Jeb Bush of having low-energy next to
Ben Carson he's Cirque du Soleil
Duffey how do you even go after dr. ben
Carson it's like debating one of those
relaxation tapes of ocean waves I I kept
saying did Bill Cosby give him something
much for once a Republican debate has
emerged with a clear winner and it is
the woman Hillary Clinton
you